حل فصل الشتاء في اوكرانيا وبدا يفرد
ايقاعه على طرفي الحرب
استمرت المعارك على اكثر من محور لتحقيق
اكبر قدر من المكاسب الميدانيه قبل ان يشد
البرد تبدو قوات الطرفين في سباق مع الزمن
فبعد اسبوع من الان ستنزل درجات الحراره
الى ناقص 10 تقول الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
روسيا تعد لحمله جديده من القصف على
منشاتها الكهربائيه يتحدث عمده كياب عن
الاضرار التي لحقت بشبكه الكهرباء ويقول
ان النسبه 40% من التيار معطره تتهم
اوكرانيا روسيا باستخدام البرد السلاحا
وبفرد ظروف قاسيه على المدنيين وترد روسيا
بانها لا تستهدف الا المنشات التي لا
ارتباط بالجيش الاوكراني في هذه الاجواء
تواصل القوات الاوكرانيه واجلاء المدنيين
من مدينه خيرسون التي ساعدتها مؤخرا تجري
عمليات الاجلاء في ظروف صعبه
باحوال الجو ولان المدينه تتعرض بقصف من
مواقع القوات الروسيه التي انسحبت اليها
وراء نهر دنيبر تقول كيف ان لديها معلومات
بان القوات الروسيه تعد بعمليات قصف مكثفه
على خرص خلال الايام المقبله اما رئيس
تونس الموالي لروسيا فيتحدث عن نقد كيف
مقاتلين من الاحتياط من خلص الى دونيتسك
للمشاركه في المعارك في جبهه لوغانس قالت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها سدتها هجمات
عده وقتلت اكثر من 160 جندي اوكرانيا
وارغمت القوات الاوكرانيه عن العوده الى
مواقع الاصليه في منطقه اركيف ويستمر
الجدل بشان محطه بروج النوويه فقد نفت
روسيا على لسان المتحدث باسم الكربلا من
متر بريسكوب من المحطه قال ان ذلك لم يحدث
ولم يحدث
بعد ان اعلنت السلطات اوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه في المحطه النوويه ستكون مرغمه
على الانسحاب امام الهجمات المضاده التي
تشلها القوات الاوكرانيه في المنطقه يعني
في الكريم فكره الانسحاب في وقت تتحدث فيه
السلطات مواليه له عن حجم كياب اكثر من
700 جندي من القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه في
محيط بروجيا استعدادا لاقتحام لمحطه
النوويه في المقاطعه يستمر الكر والفر اذن
في حرب لا يبدو انها ستضع اوزارها قريبا
ويبدو ان الاوكرانيين استسلموا لهذا
الاهتمام وبداوا يعدون لعده لفصل شتاء صعب
يتوقعوا ان تزداد فيه قسوه الحرب في بلد
تنزل فيه درجات الحراره احيانا الى ناقص